so if you live in beijing you complain
about the traffic it's some of the worst
in the world but now because of this
shadow lockdown
there's just really not nearly as many
cars about it is a lot quieter slightly
eerie
they've had a case in this block which
means that everyone
now has to stay inside they can get
deliveries in there but you can see this
fence
and it's bad luck to be stuck inside but
the real bad luck is if you test
positive and you're taken to one of the
quarantine hospitals
the reason for these measures is that
the vaccination rate in china especially
amongst the elderly is very low so we're
seeing more of these mobile buses around
the loudspeakers saying you can get your
booster here you can get it for free
some people going it's not especially
busy though maybe because everyone's
been told to stay at home
so this is something that's becoming
part of daily life really a trip to get
a pcr test this is the third day of mass
testing for three and a half million
people here but you need a test to get
into a supermarket a negative test
within 48 hours so everyone here just
kind of does this regularly it's pretty
easy
just do your passport uh in heart
schools libraries gyms hairdressers
restaurant bars they're all shut people
have been told to work from home it
looks a lot like a lockdown even if
authorities are refusing to use that
word there's no end to it in sight